the pandemic has kept teenagers across
the world out of school
in some places this has had devastating
consequences
the number of teen pregnancies has been
soaring at least one million more
underage girls have become pregnant
since the pandemic began
most in developing countries
many of them victims of sexual abuse
welcome to the covert 19 special i'm
rebecca ritters
uganda is among those countries that
have seen a spike in teenage pregnancies
since schools were shut due to the
pandemic rights groups warned that
lockdowns have exposed girls who would
otherwise have been in class to sexual
exploitation and abuse
is 17 years old
and already has a baby
she was a student in eastern uganda
until schools closed last year to stop
the spread of kovi 19.
vaila returned home and then got
pregnant
i was afraid my mom was so angry with me
i ran away from home but returned later
while her school remained closed viola
helped her mother run a restaurant
that's where she met the man who
impregnated her
viola's mother says that her daughter
was safe in school
if the schools hadn't closed she
wouldn't have gotten pregnant that's a
fact
this is violent school
like all schools across the country
it remains closed
and abandoned
the teachers here are worried that the
more their students are kept from school
the more these teenagers are exposed to
abuse
during this time at home kids have
learned things that we didn't know about
at their age
remember this is a digital age where
children watch pornography on phones and
try out stuff
even the churches that would have helped
the children remain closed so many kids
are largely on their own
according to government figures before
the pandemic
one out of four adolescent girls fell
pregnant in uganda
this has grown to nearly one in three
girls in some villages the unfpa also
blames the growth in teenage pregnancies
on rising poverty
if like a girl doesn't have money to buy
cards for example and there's someone
who can provide some money for for the
park then they find that they are
vulnerable those who are
poor they tend to
they tend to marry off
the girls it's like a business they when
the moment they matter of the girls
definitely
then they get a bright price in terms of
animals in terms of money
in uganda sex with a minor below the age
of 18 is punishable with a maximum
sentence of death
but the police say that
prosecution is challenging
victims are often compromised by
cultural traditions which mostly protect
the male culprit
we have a lot of cultural beliefs that
are very harmful
child marriage in some communities is
allowed
people think some of these cases are not
police matters they don't even report
them to police
they go they sit with the llc they
exchange
gifts
the government is now vaccinating
teachers to first track the reopening of
schools
viola hopes to resume studies but with a
baby to take care of
learning may never be the same for the
young mother
viola's story is far from an isolated
case the world health organization
estimates there are some 10 million
unwanted teenage pregnancies in the
developing world each year
more than five million of those are
aborted with the vast majority of those
procedures performed unsafely unsafely
pregnancy and childbirth complications
are the leading cause of death in girls
age between 15 and 19 worldwide
for more on this i'm joined on the line
by irene kaguya from world vision in
uganda irene thanks very much for
joining us welcome to the program can
you explain to us how covert 19 has
contributed so much to this increase in
abuse and exploitation
thank you so much
the situation of violence against
children in uganda and many parts of
africa
has been
one that is difficult to deal with
because cases of violence have been
there even before covet 19 but with the
outbreak the situation wasn't in as much
as government put up measures to control
the spread of the pandemic unfortunately
these measures have
indirectly affected the well-being of
many children
for instance the closures of schools
have really impacted on children
especially the girl child
schools served as a soft net for many
girls but now with
schools closed the girls cannot access
information on their sexual and
reproductive health
the girls are now spending more time
with
male
friends and
men in the communities and yet when they
were in school they spent more time
studying while at school
we also at school they received guidance
and counseling which is not feasible
anymore with the continued closure of
schools but also the economic hardships
in many of the communities in uganda and
many parts of africa
due to the pandemic we saw many families
lose their livelihoods as
a result of job loss we saw children and
families struggling really to earn a
living during the lockdown and as such
they're exposed to
vulnerabilities for instance as you
heard in the video that even where
someone cannot afford a pad they they
become vulnerable to anyone who would
may want to take advantage of them
and we also saw lots of cases of
gender-based violence happening in homes
which ultimately exposed them to more
violence including teenage pregnancy
so clearly a lot of issues there and a
lot of impacts on the the girls but what
sort of physical impact does it have on
these young women on their bodies having
a child so early
honestly uh for some people they've
called it one of the worst forms of
child labor because when you look at
this child she's barely
ready to carry a child
and
we've had situations where they'll
suffer complications
uh right after bath or even during bath
and resulting to death like you have are
indicated in the report but also one of
the big
challenges we have noticed with teenage
pregnancy is the stigma that these girls
suffer within the communities and within
families some of these girls have been
sent away by their parents of course
disappointed but like any other parent
so in cases where a parent is not able
to support them children have been left
to the support of charitable
organizations
and we've seen uh these girls ending up
in the hands of
other
sort of societies that cannot support
them they end up on the streets
trying to fend and survive
and in worst case scenarios we've seen
these girls suffer depression where they
expose themselves to alcoholism and
drugs because
they are frustrated
that either their dreams have come to an
end due to uh the teenage pregnancy just
a devastating situation irene kaguya
we're gonna have to leave it there thank
you very much for speaking to us
you're welcome
well now we come to the part of the show
dedicated to your questions here to
answer them is our correspondent derek
williams
does the vaccine give you different
protection than recovering from the
virus does
this is complicated but the short answer
is is yes
both infection with the pathogen and
being vaccinated against that pathogen
generate protective immune responses but
but they're different on a number of
levels how could they not be
during an infection through the nose and
throat
the body is confronted with rapidly
replicating saris cov2 while
most vaccines injected in the arm
work by only confronting the immune
system with a critical coronavirus
feature
the spike that studs its outer surface
among other things that means an
infection provokes the body to produce
a wider range of antibodies
than vaccines will the antibodies they
prompt are are more narrowly focused on
the spike but many experts think that
narrow
but powerful focus is a positive thing
others think it could become a problem
if the spike proteins mutate even
further in new variants but the truth is
we don't really know at this point which
of the two
infection or vaccination provides better
or or longer lasting protection
there are studies making that claim in
both directions but there are two
important points touching on this topic
that i think
have to be made the first
is that we have good evidence that
protection for people who have survived
a covet 19 infection can be dramatically
strengthened if if after recovery
they go ahead and get vaccinated as well
which is why healthcare authorities
recommend definitely doing that
the second point
is that given the choice
being vaccinated is a much safer way to
acquire protection from covid19
than getting the disease and surviving
it
that might provide you with an excellent
defensive response
against stars kobe 2 in the future but
there's also a chance
that you
wouldn't live to enjoy it
[Music]
most of new zealand has moved out of
lockdown easing restrictions on
wednesday except for the largest city
auckland which will remain in the
strictest type of lockdown until at
least next week that city has been
battling an outbreak of the delta
variant for the past month new zealand
was largely virus free until an infected
traveler from australia ceded the
current outbreak
well that's our show for today if you'd
like more on any of our stories you'll
find that and much more on our website
dw.com forward slash covert 19 we'll be
back again at the same time tomorrow
hope to see you then thanks for watching
[Music]
you